so in other words you have this vast
associative web inside your head
that's embodying information about all
your previous experiences and knowledge
and information that you learn newly
will have to make sense and be
referenced or grounded by this
associational web that's how it enters
it so again this is just an entirely
different paradigm of how we learn right
and how we think then how a computer
does it boom what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host on Sathyan
we are at the brain and cognitive
sciences building at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology in the beautiful
Cambridge Massachusetts we are now going
to be talking about the differences
between brains and computers we have dr.
Robert Oh Jim yan joining us on the show
hello how are you doing thank you so
much for coming online pleasure I'm
super excited robert's backgrounds epic
he's a research scientist at MIT is
McGovern Institute for brain research a
professor of brain and cognitive
sciences at MIT and he teaches a
computational neuroscience class titled
emerging computation and distributed
neural circuits and studies the science
of mnemonic techniques and you can find
his link below he's also a fellow
Armenian haha and check out his link
super interesting stuff up there let's
jump into this question that we love
starting with we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what is your current
take on the state of our world well
obviously I think the state of our world
is failing in numerous respects and
there's a geopolitical answer and then a
more personal answer so the geopolitical
answer is that as humans are
transforming the planet the recent UN
report on all the species vanishing
etcetera we're not necessarily taking
actions to counter that so that's a big
problem but that's one that I can't do
too much about I am concerned that the
scientists know what we're doing is
going too far and pushing the planet to
its limits but the policymakers aren't
necessarily
listening properly and taking corrective
actions so that's on the big
geopolitical level but again that
doesn't necessarily affect me on the
personal level what concerns me more on
the personal level is that as our
society has become more technologically
driven with social media is a ssin of
the entire planet
I'm concerned that the way that humans
think has been transformed in a not
propitious way in particular it strikes
me that with all of these electronic
devices and contraptions that a lot of
our thinking in a lot of our daily
behavior is all stimulus to driven ok we
see a beep we read a text we see these
things and we respond it's all short
burst of attention and quick thinking
and I don't think that's necessarily
conducive to say academic scientific
problem solving some of my colleagues
ridicule me for being what they call a
technophobe because I don't have a
smartphone and I'm not a technophobe I
think technology has a lot of good uses
but I think one of the downsides of
technology is that it interferes with
people to sustain their attention for a
long time on hard problems because
you're always being perturbed by the
electronic influx of information from a
variety of sources and you kind of see
this in what's happened to the current
scientist the current scientists
nowadays is not sitting in his death
thinking for 4 or 5 hours a day I try to
do that I don't maintain that ideal but
I think a reasonable amount of time
they're constantly managing they become
big project managers as if they're in
industry because you've got lots of
grants you've got to write these reports
you've got lots of students you got to
handle this administrative aspect you
gotta handle this administrative aspect
you're always on your smartphone answer
email texting with students I don't
think that's the way thoughtful science
can be done
which is you really need to maintain a
lot of internal focus to solve hard
problems and God knows the brain
presents lots of hard problems being one
of the last undiscovered regions of
scientific inquiry we know very little
about the brain relative to almost every
other natural phenomenon Michelangelo
probably would not have been able to
spend over three years sculpting the
Statue of David if there was social
media oh I completely agree but even go
to like I mean think about Einstein or
you know how would he you know survive
in this kind of an environment with all
these burdens and responsibilities and
electronic buzzing back and forth I mean
you just need to sit and think and if
that's done nowadays that's considered a
sign of unproductivity right because
everything is stimulus driven and
response driven and there's a sense the
time scale has increased for everything
right everything is rapid everything is
instant gratification there's no sense
of delayed gratification now what people
want to do when they write a paper is
get it out on the World Wide Web get
lots of hits get lots of immediate
citations they're not writing the paper
for what people used to write to the
paper for which is will it be around in
50 years yes what's the indication of
whether it's good work it's not how many
hits you get through some kind of
advertising or branding it's about how
enduring is that work over time because
history will get it right in terms of
science there's right and there's wrong
on I can say art where it's a matter of
taste and people pass through different
phases so work that's enduring will be
known there's an interesting article by
two guys Gaiman and Gaiman I think I
sent it to you about what's it called
science in the age of selfies yes and it
talks about some of these trends where
scientists are basically interested in
photographing themselves right instead
of using your example slowly doing a
landscape of a faraway horizon and
that's unfortunate another famous one
the we wanted flying cars and we got 140
characters that's a yes absolutely great
I mean I don't even understand I don't
see how this can help students write
read or think when they're operating
with Twitter you just don't understand
that so just one of the like quick
arguments on behalf of it is that you
can get a piece of news from around the
world disseminated effectively to lots
of people I agree and that's that's one
of the core arguments for it and we both
agree and then at but at the same time a
lot of the profound thinkers and
executors scientists artists of the of
the days before us were able to be at
complete silence and peace at by
themselves and you also highlighted the
can you create something that has a
Linde effect can it withstand the test
of time and I do think that whatever
satoshi nakamoto whatever blockchain
whoever that is whatever it is ended up
potentially making something that will
last several decades and so I do think
that creating things like that and
focusing on creating things like that is
way more important than what some of the
perverse scientific incentives are in
our in our systems today I agree
completely and again all technology's
advantages for example the internet I
use internet I mean think about I can
get a paper from any journal you know as
long as we have subscriptions at the
university that I'd have to go to the
library
maybe my library what happened so
information flow is a good thing the
problem is do people have the discipline
to police themselves internally or can
this thing kind of escalate out of
control and from my point of view it's
kind of escalated out of control some
people have the discipline to police
themselves somes don't but the younger
generation being thrust in it is not
gonna know the difference and won't even
be able to police themselves especially
because then
News Feed has become a slot machine and
that's one of the addictive strategies
of a reward system that's varied yeah
yeah and one of the ironies of the fact
that information is so accessible is
that now no one reads I mean you talk
about scientists today versus fifty
years ago my boss Emilio beats a
tremendous individual he still reads to
this day most people don't read journal
articles why there's no time you've got
to get out you've got to get out you've
got to go on Twitter you got to promote
yourself you've got to promote your
brand you've got to do all these things
right and even just like people say
Facebook has made people lonelier
ironically same thing rampant or great
access to information which if used
properly is undeniably a great thing has
somehow led to people reading less yeah
so that's not a good outcome yeah and we
got to be very careful and I think one
of the phrases that can help us get
there is signal-to-noise we have to
really be able to identify what is true
knowledge how can we get that into these
feeds more effectively all right let's
do the journey yeah how did you as a
child get inspired by neuroscience and
computation and then find yourself well
actually I did not intend not ever on
being a neuroscientist what I intended
on being was a mathematician physicist
in fact when I went to college I studied
math and physics and I enjoyed math and
physics but I realized that my area of
facility and expertise is in theory and
in terms of physics in particular the
amount of of jobs or even the need for
theorists is relatively small there
aren't that many theaters necessary
whereas then I looked towards various
medical problems including neuroscience
I'm like boy we know very little about
this so maybe a theorist can make a big
difference there as a result a few years
after I graduated enrolled in an
excellent program at Boston University
called the Department of cognitive
neural systems which was basically a
theoretical neuroscience program so the
idea was
you're not going to do experiments
you're gonna figure out how to come up
with frameworks that will allow us to
interpret the results in these
experiments
maybe codify all these experiments to
develop theories of various motor
sensory cognitive behaviors circuits in
the brain and that's what I became and
passionate about and ever since I have
not regretted that decision and then one
more bit is how did you even pre physics
and math and get hooked into it would
you have mentors or any family what was
the big thing for you that sparked the
interest I don't know I always liked
math and physics ever since I was a kid
because I was amazed at the ability to
predict and control how things happen in
nature it's almost like magical this
ability to make some calculations on a
piece of paper and Wow well that's true
understanding of the system right and so
when I realized how far to jump forward
from the brain we are actually making
any predictions about this stuff I'm
like wouldn't it be great if the brain
could just be nudged
a step towards these remarkable
predictions you can make in physics and
with a few strokes on a piece of paper
you can say what's gonna happen with
great certainty its debt just always
amazed me that's beautiful
okay and then the PhD itself the
analysis of movement representation in
motor cortical cells at Boston
University sure so when I got very
interested at the time and I was
personally interested in motor control
because I actually am a fairly avid
tennis player I played tennis and so how
do you learn a skill how do you maintain
a skill why is it that you never forget
how to ride a bike the person comes back
from playing tennis after not playing
for five years and they seem to be able
to hit the stroke pretty well so these
were problems that all fascinated me in
systems neuroscience and motor control
so what I specifically studied for my
dissertation was something called the
encoding problem and the encoding
problem is how is information about
upcoming movements
represented as a series of commands in
the brain okay
in other words roger federer wants to go
hit a forehand that must trigger a
cascade of events from intention at the
higher levels of the frontal cortex to
the motor cortical output to the spinal
cord thereby telling his muscles what
steps to take to hit his forehand
cross-court and that's kind of a
fascinating problem I focused on the
motor cortex which is the region that
projects to the spinal cord and that got
me interested actually in the
differences in brains and computers
which is something that as you know I've
been pursuing since because it turns out
that I came out I want to set out to
come up with this beautiful mathematical
formalism to explain if information is
represented in this nice coordinate
system this is how it's encoded in the
brain if it's represented like this this
is how it's encoded in the brain at the
end of the day I realized early during
my postdoc that that's great but that's
kind of a computer perspective
unfortunately the brain doesn't obey any
of these rules the question is do these
concepts that we impose from anthropic
anthropomorphic perspective even make
sense so my thesis which I'm still very
proud of kind of changed my direction in
the sense that if the assumptions were
correct the work was nice and beautiful
the question is are those assumptions
even correct for the brain and if not
where do you go next and so I've been
trying to follow those secondary
directions like maybe it's not such a
nice system like a computer program we
would write to implement these things
it's a different type of system obeying
a different set of rules and we need to
focus on those even the example of being
able to take a thought from an executive
function state down to
motor cortex down to the spinal cord
down to the muscle to hit back the ball
is a very profound way of analyzing
something that is seems to be quite at
the surface level just a simple tennis
Oh people think it's simple the
complexities are remarkable and this is
why while they've been successes in AI
there's no AI device even near Roger
Federer in its ability to play tennis
and we can get into maybe some of that
later but the point is motor control is
an incredibly complicated problem of
appreciated and appreciated difficulty
compared to something like an image
recognition object recognition these
problems are simpler and smaller
dimensional and it's very interesting
that the time skills to do something
like an object recognition seems to
almost you know be here it's really it
is we are ready to do that there are
other problems we are not ready for and
God knows when will it be ready for them
yeah yeah click on that point where does
the thought of in the milliseconds of
time of calculating where the ball got
hit back where does it originate in the
executive functioning well it's that's a
part of the brain that makes it
difficult to study is even that question
is some extent ill-posed because it's a
highly distributed representation that's
represented in parallel in multiple
places so I could give you some
canonical answer with you know the
frontal cortex has the goals and then
you do this dream back but it's really
everywhere it's also in the cerebellum
it's also in the basal ganglia these
circuits are all interacting in parallel
so our whole serial understanding based
on the kind of the computer metaphor for
how these things work is it adequate for
understanding of the brain works it's
just more complicated than that and we
don't know all the answers yeah yeah
this is going to be a reoccurring
unfortunately regarding the brain not
knowing the answers is more than norm
than the exception
it's extremely important to be humble
and admit that
that that that is the case so let's talk
about these differences between
computers and brains you really gave us
a really good one right there which is
that there's just so much parallel
circuitry that is being that is
understanding the stimuli of the
environment and making decision in a
return so keep going on these chairs you
chose transmission speed clot rate clock
repair mechanism yeah all these
different things so brains are composed
of neurons and synapses right those are
the fundamental units and computers are
loosely speaking constructive chips so
let's just take simply operating
characteristics of these smaller units
neurons and chips before we even get
into higher level systems differences
like parallelism etc what is the clock
rate for a computer you know that's how
many gigahertz you have right it's how
many computations can be performed per
second roughly on the order of say 10 to
the ninth it's probably higher for some
of the faster computers and that just
keeps going up it's ten to the ninth
what's the speed with which say neurons
can compute things well I know I can
only spike that's the way information is
transmitted from one neuron to another
with an electrical signal sent down its
axon where it stimulates the dendrite of
the neighboring neuron I would say about
200 spikes per second would be really
high so you know let's say best-case
scenario 10 to the third is this clock
rate 10 to the third being about order
of you know one spike per millisecond
which is probably faster than we can we
can do so you have 10 to the ninth for
the computer ten to the third for nerd
what about signal transmission how fast
does that signal move along the axon
well in computers electric signals
obviously travel the speed of light
which is if I recall correctly roughly
10 to the 8 meters per second how fast
do signals move along axons well roughly
10 to the second meters per second so 10
to the ninth 10 to the
third four o'clock raked into the eighth
ten to the second four signal
transmission speed what about noise
signal to noise ratio Computers
basically the problem of noise is solved
if you run a program the same way you
always get the same answer right there's
very little noise in these circuits some
thermal noise it's estimated around ten
to the sixth which is ten to the six
signal ratio to the noise ratio in the
neurons it's hard to estimate
signal-to-noise ratio because we don't
even really know what the signal is but
it's on the ballpark of one you know
charitably ten all right so the noise is
very very significant all right so if
you look at these just these three
operating characteristics and we can
discuss some of the system's level
differences as well you have ten to the
sixth that's the order of magnitude
difference between these operating
characteristics so then why is the
computer used as a metaphor and there's
a good reason why the computers used as
a metaphor right I mean there have been
all kinds of metaphors about the brain
throughout history hydraulic engines
watches right Electrical telephone
signals right the prevailing technology
at the time and many articles and books
have been written about this is
generally the leading metaphor for the
brain because the brain obviously is
capable of the most remarkable functions
possible so I want to match that with
whatever technology is capable and this
dates back since the you know ancient
Greece which at the time of ancient
Greece basically these different
metaphors have evolved over time so now
we are able to get computers to do very
very remarkable things because we can do
remarkable things with computers because
we can do remarkable things with our
brains there's a natural tendency to say
brains and computers are alike they're
not ok how we're doing those things is
entirely different and then you mention
the other is parallelism right computers
do not work in parallel there's some
efforts at doing parallel processing
neuromorphic engineering none of those
up and down
standard computers operate basically in
series and very rapidly okay so the
motif for computing in a computer is
lots of serial computations in the brain
you got the slow sloppy imprecise
computing but it's highly parallelized
and that's because each neuron in the
brain connects to 10 to the fourth other
neurons roughly 10,000 other neurons
that's a rule of thumb some are more and
some are less but the whole architecture
is different you may be you've heard of
that game six ways to Kevin Bacon or six
connections you Kevin Bacon a degree six
degrees of separation right Kevin and so
you start with one name and then you
make these associative jumps well
something like that actually existed the
brain it's called a small world
architecture and the idea is that no
synapse anywhere in the brain is more
than three or four synapses removed from
affecting some other synapse so these
are just Testaments to the degree to
which there's this parallel architecture
where everything is talking to
everything simultaneously but somehow
the system is organized in a way that
it's able to make sense it at all and
perform these remarkable functions ok
but this doesn't mean you're doing it
any way like the brain is doing it in
fact again the differences are striking
how did these object recognition
algorithms manage to all of a sudden
perform at this human level of
performance was it because there are
architectural changes the architectures
been the same since the early 80s is it
because there are any algorithmic
changes now I algorithm has been the
same since the 70s what's changed is
processing speed and the amount of data
particularly Fred of Moore's law
processing speed doubling what is it
every two years or something that has
been maintained for a long time this is
what's going on we are good we have
developed a technology to enslave
electronic circuits for performing
trillions and trillions of calculations
nations in series to perform tasks
amenable to those operations and that's
why object recognition has been a
problem where we've made a lot of
progress it's not going to be the same
for all the problems as I said the
problem with motor control with Roger
Federer for a variety of reasons you
have all these interaction torques
between all the degrees of freedom of
your body it's a continuous problem as
opposed to a discrete categorization
problem those are hard problems all
right when there's a computer or robot
that can play tennis like Roger Federer
then we've solved those problems it's
gonna be a long time before we ever get
to the stage because it's just a
different type of intelligence okay
artificial intelligence will work better
for some emulating some types of natural
intelligence than others now you talked
about differences between the computers
in the brains let me give you another
strong one which also harkens to an area
where I do research as I was discussing
mnemonic techniques and so a question is
how is information stored and processed
in the brain in the brain information is
stored in bits in these registers right
I have my one zero one zero one zero one
zero deuced to a binary code and I have
an address by which I can connect to
that register so if I want information
somewhere I need the address okay then I
go to the information so one point about
that information is that it's segregated
it's localized it's only there okay and
the address is what connects the user to
that information the brain is entirely
different okay all information is stored
relationally association 'le in terms of
its content and it's all in a
distributed fashion meaning that
information is encoded in distributed
activation patterns that share neurons
for different pieces of information it's
not segregated in one register it's
spread everywhere okay and I don't have
someone reading it with an address it's
organized by Kahn
tenth so in other words you have this
vast associative web inside your head
that's embodying information about all
your previous experiences and knowledge
and information that you learn newly
will have to make sense and be
referenced or grounded by this
associational web that's how it enters
it so again this is just an entirely
different paradigm of how we learn right
and how we think then how a computer
does it and one way that you can see
this is in the use of mnemonic
techniques to improve people's memory I
don't know how much your audience is
familiar with it lots of people aren't
familiar with it but are these ancient
techniques dating back to Greece
civilization gentleman named Simone et's
and even actually further back than that
and if you apply these techniques which
I'll just describe very cursorily you
can remember huge pieces of information
now why was this important well in the
old days papyrus was expensive they
don't have computers there was no
printing press so you'd want to learn
vast pieces of information you want to
memorize your speeches etc people
practiced at this okay and all of these
techniques were based on Association you
would take some new information and
you'd relate it to some old information
and then you'd concoct some kind of
story up and voila the magic of these
techniques was that it became really
easy to remember lots of things this is
now a lost art we completely ignore
memory because we have these electronic
devices kids are not even learning the
multiplication tables in school systems
or kid writing or handwriting right but
think about what an incredible mistake
this could be if these memory techniques
embody a more general associative
computing faculty that is being ignored
in other words if Association is a
fundamental paradigm of how we process
information ie relating new information
to old information and experience and
putting it in context and that helps us
not all
memorize things but it helps us with
pattern formation concept formation even
creativity linking different things to
each other right
it's all part of general neural
computing which we don't really
understand and if we all of a sudden
omit one major component of it memory
because the way memory is done in
computers is so easy that we have
infinite amount of memory it would be
like not running on the treadmill not
staying in shape because I can drive a
car in a train to ever I want to go
right that one makes sense
you got to exercise the fundamental
faculties of your brain and if
Association in memory is only one
instantiation of it is an important
faculty and you're ignoring it that's a
problem but you only realize that if you
try to think carefully in a nuanced
fashion what are the differences between
how the brain works and how a computer
works and they are profound the
differences are far greater than
similarities only similarities is that
they're both capable of remarkable feats
yeah that was very eloquently explained
and I think that there's potentially
some ways that we can break this down to
make it even I continue to make it
really relatable so when a child is
first recognizing and being taught what
an object is and what we do with that
object like these chairs what we do is
we sit in these chairs and what the or
call this a chair and then then that
practice happens then there's set in
different languages as well sure okay
so we're building an associative web of
exactly yes of what we do with the
object what it objects called if what it
means to us how it feels to us the
purpose it serves for us this is
basically the grounding problem right I
mean the object doesn't exist in a
vacuum
it exists relative to our lives and how
we use it right and that grounding
problem
it has to be solved for biological
organisms but you don't need to ground
anything in a computer it's not so so
what what about it could it could it
potentially be that the amount of time
that it takes for a child to learn what
the chair the associative web of
information about the chair is just a
lot longer than what it could be for a
computer and then is there a way to
ground the computer into the meaning for
various technical reasons I don't think
it's possible it's a little bit of a
theoretical discussion to possible to
ground the computer but this grounding
happens naturally in humans for a
variety of reasons I said or any
biological origins one is you got right
this small world's architecture in your
brain so the sensory areas are speaking
to the goal areas are speaking to the
motor areas they are all in
communication with these cyclic
redundant loops so everything is seeing
everything on multiple levels and scales
so as a result of that you are naturally
learning the object at multiple levels
or as of now like a computer how you
going to give it Drive how you gonna
give it motivation why you could program
it to do this etc that's fine but it's
not really solving the grounding problem
in the sense that it doesn't have an
innate intrinsic complicated purpose in
the world to which its able to naturally
relate all phenomena tow it to it on
multiple levels and scales and that's
the unique feature about animal
intelligence a particular human
intelligence you do these things
naturally yeah and to be able to build
an associative web for robot that is
trying to compete against the world's
best tennis players is much harder right
now than it is to have the perception
systems of an autonomous vehicle that
already has so many cameras that we
don't have we only get to look forward
and we can we have to turn around versus
the slurping of data that is able to be
done so there do see so we are we're
already seeing
sophistication yeah absolutely yeah yeah
speak about this very well the case of
object recognition and again I don't
want to get too technical on it but this
is a problem that essentially can be
overcome with Big Data and Moore's Law
all right
so in order to saw and then I don't
think self-driving cars are as near our
future as people say because I just
think they don't really generalize so
all of a sudden it's a cloudy rainy day
something bad is going to happen all
right you know you can train it on all
the data you want when you put it out in
the real world something Bad's going to
happen
is something different is going to
happen and that's going to cause
consequences but that being said
certainly the performance of object
recognition systems clearly rivals human
performance and that just happens to be
a problem where big data and computing
power can overcome it and a for a
variety of reasons motor control is a
harder problem in part because I have
many degrees of freedom to my body and
they all interact in highly complex
nonlinear ways and so if you're going to
hit a ground stroke and move your arm
the degrees of freedom and the
continuous signal necessaries in such a
high dimensional space that I can't
really overcome it with a lot of
training data and Moore's law that's
computing power I can't throw training
data and computing power at every
problem some problems are more amenable
that to others and this unfortunately is
a an aspect of artificial intelligence
that's completely neglected by the AI
community that they just want to keep
throwing these success stories the the
algorithms behind current success
stories to future problems without
thinking well maybe I need to match the
problem to the architecture I want to
see what your thoughts are on this to
see if we can continue on this relatable
example we are we are working on when H
when a child's born we're working on
effectively helping that child build a
mental map an associative web of its
reality yes C's too for it to be able to
find a meaning or purpose in the world
make its basic physiological needs be
met absolutely and so that is kind of
the
this general way that we're trying to
help with this mental model okay all
right and then with and it seems like
everything right now with the artificial
intelligences are very narrow
intelligences highly constrained highly
constrained intelligences and I really
enjoyed all the ways that you you know
that you really you're really helping
out with this associative web verses
these narrow and also just just neurons
versus computer chips these are there
there's gonna be some sort of a weird
potentially Venn diagram plus new things
that are we have yet to really think
about them yeah but no one's in that
space right now because everyone's
dominated by what's called deep nets
which is the current architecture that's
successful in a few problems and no
one's actually thinking logically about
well how far can this go as you probably
know there's this is the third AI
revolution first one started in 5758 by
a guy named Rosenblatt did excellent
work then Minsky and pop a both of whom
were at MIT showed that these networks
couldn't solve certain problems next
revolution came when rummel hard-hitting
McClellan Williams and a bunch of people
at Stanford came up with parallel
distributed processing they had back
prop current algorithms and architecture
behind today's AI that work they went
fairly far and then booms support vector
machines which was a different simpler
algorithm overcame them
so everyone forgot about them but
Moore's law kept cranking along and
eventually the guy you mentioned the
Russian guy in Hinton the Cameron burrs
name came out with that paper in 2012 oh
yeah yeah eventually the computing power
and the data got big enough so that all
of a sudden wow you can do object
recognition in a level that rivals
humans its support vector machines fell
by the wayside what's going to happen
now right I mean these cycles repeat if
you don't understand history you're
doomed to repeat it there are going to
be some limitations to these problems
that are discovered it's better that we
discover that sooner than later so great
in some dough
they work we use them we enrich our
society in our community through their
use and you were literally just teaching
a class where I got the privilege to sit
down and and see your students debating
about what the limitations are on not a
deep nets and that was so interesting
that you're already trying to push with
different tools push the edge yeah
because what I want is I want people to
think about different paradigms for
understanding the brain this is still
the unexplored scientific country we do
not know how it works if we just relax
our guard and say well deep nets do
certain things well we're not going to
explore sloppy slow modes of parallel
computing that somehow miraculously give
rise to the it works our brains work
animal brains work we don't know why
they work so well but there's something
about them that is truly exceptional
that's what we need to discover and to
just use the algorithm and architecture
that's most relatable to our current
computing device the computer and to say
well maybe that's how the brain works
that's not even ignorant and it's not
true full circling back to the constant
age of stimulus versus the longer slower
focused periods of creative endeavor and
creative exploration so what is what is
that process that's occurring in the
mind and sure it feels like it's a it's
a height it's a hijacking of the
short-term I agree so essentially if you
buy into this framework of Association
being an important part of our computing
anything we can do to enhance our
associative infrastructure will help our
brains do their thing right for as I
said for mnemonic techniques people put
a lot of their old information in order
and then when they learn new information
they mesh the old information and the
new information so they kind of expand
the web and sleep is so good well swoop
is very important for everything right
so without sleep you're just not going
to have a healthy brain function
absolutely it helps consolidate it helps
everything now if someone is just
basically stimulus driven they're not
going to be forming certain high order
associations that are forming low-level
peripheral associations kind of stimulus
response type behavior we want to go
deeper than that we want to create
associative infrastructure from
radically different parts of our brain
this one mnemonic expert Skye Jim
Carroll that is a good friend of mine
he's the man who has the greatest
long-term memory in the world as far as
we know and he just knows a ridiculous
amount of information they did an fMRI
on his brain and he's got these really
thick tracks communicating information
from one part to the other one I mean
it's not a surprise right if you spend a
lot of time building associations you're
gonna build your associative
infrastructure it's hard to do that if
you're basically doing stimulus response
this text this thing this button right I
mean you got to think deeply to create
new novel meaningful associations yes
yes
and so these meaningful associations I
think are potentially some of the most
important ways to both push the edge of
knowledge with different fields
connecting different fields but also to
figure out the associations between the
existing fields and figuring out how to
make it relatable more relatable for
children to be able to give Rockit them
out faster to the edge of neuroscience
or to the edge of a different field
because the it it's it's both this pull
interplay between pushing the edge
further connecting different vertices on
the edge and then I think a really
strong synthesizer and a person that
knows metaphors and analogies absolutely
yeah the more information you put in
your brain the more likely you are to
create
the right connections for new creative
insights and discoveries right this is
why you can't defer all of your memory
to Google and to electronic devices you
need to have ideas in your head so
you're constantly hypothesis testing
you're comparing things if you want to
be a scientist you shouldn't just know
your science you should know related
scientists are you're saying so that
then you can go at the inter
disciplinary boundaries make connections
what principles carry over from here to
there one of the best aspects of my
training for computational neuroscience
was the fact that I took classes not
just in physics and math but biology and
chemistry so when I had a broad
scientific background that prepared me
to think about the brain on scientific
terms as opposed to a lot of people who
just think of it in terms of engineering
in computer science terms which is in my
opinion obviously not the app metaphor
and now I wonder on these techniques
that are really old that help with
mnemonics I want to know is where where
you sit on memory palaces on meditation
on long periods of focus so teach us
about where you sit on these ancient
second chair and how they can help us so
the way the ancient memory techniques
work is is very simple it's method of
Llosa memory palace etc and I'll just do
it very quickly
you have some part of your personal
experience some for example set of
locations on your route to school your
journey to school or the rooms of the
house you grew up with or anything like
that where you have a cereal ordering of
information the form of a spatial map
that's kind of your old skeleton
structure of information now I want to
learn say all the capitals of the world
then what you do is you take a capital
the first capital you put it in the
first room you tell some story that
helps you remember it that's an
associative technique and then you go to
the second one the third one etc and the
techniques are obviously much more
elaborate than that and they involve all
kinds of different types of Association
but but that's the basic structure you
have
old information you have new information
you merge the two using the Faculty of
Association and what's remarkable about
this is your memory goes up a ridiculous
amount there's this old paper about the
magic number seven you may have heard of
it's one of the most cited papers and
all sociology who's written a little bit
tongue-in-cheek by Harvard psychologists
what the work here yeah working memory
seven right seven plus or minus two it's
actually if you do these mnemonic
techniques you'll be up to fifty in
three months with twenty minutes a day I
mean this is documented this is not I
mean this is why this was so popular in
ancient Greece and ancient Rome and in
societies before there was a means to
record information so one perspective
would be well now we can record
information so I don't need to do this
stuff anymore and that's true I mean in
a certain sense I why do I go to the gym
if I got a bike or if I have a car but
the way that I look at it is if these
associations forming these associations
exercises a more general associate of
faculty that it's useful for pattern
recognition concept formation formation
creativity etc it's good exercise for
your mind yes
it's exercise not that there aren't
other types not the only type of
exercise I think this is one of multiple
types of exercise and another thing it
does which i think is also important
focus obviously is a big problem you
know we live in an a DD society
everything stimulus driven you're
responding the use of these mnemonic
techniques requires internal
introspection that goes to an extent
that other forms of memorization or just
accessing it online don't and it's kind
of important at least I believe for
proper intellectual development that you
sometimes turn your focus inward in
concentrate and I think meditation does
the same thing I'm no way an expert on
meditation at all but my understanding
is that it allows you kind of to focus
longer and to be in your mind and
not of the external sensory rush that's
constantly fluctuating and I think
that's good for thinking and creating
and I da ting in general you had this
really relatable example I think is when
we prepare for a presentation yeah
because we so often take our computer or
our phone or we write notes on our hand
or whatever we do versus when we have I
remember for the TEDx San Francisco talk
that I gave last year I remember
building out one of the most beautiful
imaginative structures of of for me to
be able to go and remember the pillars
on the talk that would then cascade all
of the sub points that I would already
know and so to be able to associate
senses as one of the big things and I'd
like how you gave the example of
childhood because those are such early
form memories vivid memories that if you
put the plot of the points on your walk
from the bedroom to the living room was
exactly yeah and and when you add in
these massive exaggerations and senses
that they're on that lie on that stop is
where the smell of the Apple projects in
and that's where the massive purple
elephants were led and so these are
those those ways to be able to retain
and I just I just love helping with
memory I myself want to I'm going to
continue working on it at a deeper level
because it just seems to be so critical
but I wonder on by the way it's sort of
this is not new I mean Francis Yates in
the sixties wrote the book the art of
memory and you heard of moonwalking with
Einstein by Joshua 4 I mean this stuff
is literally 2500 years old at least and
it probably dates back since the dawn of
civilization so there's nothing new
about doing this especially when the
resources that we wanted to put the
information on were so limited exactly
didn't have
the ability to H into stone like holy
cow now it's just pressing keys on a
keyboard or speaking into the device or
recording it exactly is completely
hugely different I'm curious as to the
the trade-off that occurs the
opportunity cost that occurs between
between it depends on it depends on the
weight what is the weight of the
information that you want to store
because sometimes the weight of the
information maybe I want to put into the
appendage of the technological device
and maybe that's one of those reasons
because it would be it would probably be
more difficult if for every single one
of these shows if I went and passed my
time building a memory palace on every
single point that we were gonna hit
versus having it on a whiteboard or a
computer that we could hit I got you
yeah I mean I think the point is you
want the most relevant key points to be
put in memory you can't do it all I'm
not saying we shouldn't have books or
Diaries or pieces of paper because
there's so much information you can't
retain vertically everything so this is
not a diatribe against all storage maybe
in fact I gave this interview for what
was it that German there Spiegel I think
they're Spiegel and I was so the whole
article was in German and at the end I
wasn't sure what it said so I typed it
in Google and it said something like I
am fighting against two of the greatest
adventures of all time the computer and
the printing press and I'm not fighting
against the computer or the printing
press I'm acknowledging that they're
good and they're important I'm just
saying just did you go to the gym in
order to exercise there are certain
mental exercises involving memory that
are worthwhile that's it exactly that's
it so you can't put everything in your
head and you shouldn't even try but you
know you shouldn't put nothing in your
head either so the question is where is
the balance and how far has society
tipped not for us our generation I'm
older than you but I'm really concerned
for the younger generation that doesn't
have
anything to memorize the ones they go to
school rowing up with the smartphone's
it's just exactly really you're giving a
presentation just or you're telling a
story like let's say you just literally
just want to tell one person a story
build a memory palace exactly Dori and
then you'll see how much better you can
retain it and speak about it
similar with you know meditation just go
and try it right these are try try it
and these those are old things to write
as thousands of years old so these are
not novel risky techniques of unknown
benefit what's happening to the the
neural architecture with the children
that are born with smartphones I mean
that's a complicated question I don't
know I mean I just think behaviorally
there's a bad trend towards attention
deficits when everything is stimulus
driven right when kids don't have time
to think to create by themselves and
everything is a video game or television
show or text or whatever at some level
your associative infrastructure isn't as
deep it's more peripheral it's at the
periphery where it's being built but
you're not making all the kinds of deep
cross connections that you want to make
in I'm not going to pretend I understand
how this all works at the system
neuroscience level because nobody does
but it does seem to me intuitive that
the denser you can build that web in a
meaningful way the better you'll be and
I guess I'd put it like this is a child
going to become a great mathematician if
they didn't memorize their times tables
when they're six and I would say no I'd
rather have the kid learned a times
table at the age of six I think he's
more likely to go on to be a great
mathematician because that's in his head
in memory and then he can put other
things in memory and eventually there's
enough stuff in memory he can start
doing that path assist testing you got
to put a certain amount of stuff in
there to get some good results out and
my concern is we're not putting enough
in and an educators response might be
well we need to teach critical thinking
skills instead well first of all how
well is that working but second of all
that assumes that Association
is not an important part of critical
thinking which of course it is what is
critical thinking right how would they
define it
so the idea remember this all comes from
the computer architecture computing and
memory are separate they're not in our
brains ok this is not the von Neumann
architecture computing and memory are
not separate they're integrated they're
enmeshed memory is a compute I like to
tell my class and that perplexes them a
little because they're not used to
thinking of memory as a dynamical entity
because they're not used to thinking of
content-addressable associational memory
even though we kind of know that's the
way it is from a theoretical standpoint
so you know for memory is a compute and
you want a lot of associations you don't
want your kid growing up without any of
them and what would you say right now on
the conversation you're having with your
students what are people trying to
figure out that is not the deep nets
where can we take our flashlight and
look what does it seem like is is going
to be pushing the bounds or so there are
a lot of areas one is unsupervised
learning and the idea is is that these
are very unrealistic systems where you
have a very specific error signal that's
completely biologically implausible and
then you but we managed to self organize
information kind of naturally we don't
need a kid doesn't necessarily need a
teacher he figures things out by
touching right by going around feeling
looking at things from different
perspectives sitting on it all these
different things so unsupervised
learning and there are a variety of
techniques that are out there and
they're starting to come more into
prominence self-organizing future maps
etc there's an old literature on this
that's very important that people need
to pay attention because ultimately we
can't have this teacher this tight
supervised learning system be the model
for how we learn because kids don't need
that tight supervision in order to learn
they learn on their own from exploration
and that
a self-organized type of learning also I
think the dynamical systems approach
which is ignored the dynamical systems
approach is essentially more in line
with other types of Sciences less along
the line of Tory computation where a
whole bunch of serial computations are
made instead let's think about a
dynamical system that's largely
connected in parallel but does something
useful in a short time even under noisy
conditions so there are a couple of
others all of which are challenging and
also complex systems there right the
brain is the ultimate complex system a
complex system being defined as the
whole being more than some of the parts
it exists at multiple spatial temporal
scales etc etc it's hard math to figure
out how these things work but that's
another area of math that I encourage
them a class to look into the whole
point though is that these are all
unexplored areas and none of them as of
yet have proven that useful
technologically so what dominates is
deep Nets because right now hundreds of
billions of dollars is being spent on
them for a few technological
applications so that's a great imbalance
that will ultimately be corrected again
these boom and bust cycles and it will
self-correct but the question is how
many how much financial and human
capital will be kind of miss spent in
the process and it also helps so much
that when you are with your students
that you enable this nuance discourse to
actually occur you even said there's a
lack of comity with with people being
sometimes challenged there you have a
sage on the stage and we don't feel
comfortable raising our hand and
interjecting giving a little bit of
pushback arguing a little bit in a
friendly nuanced way with love and
compassion but wanting to get to what
are the best ideas and so I want you to
speak about what that's been like as you
know a research scientist and professor
in academia how do you feel about that
well I feel science has changed for the
worse along those lines but for
understandable reasons there's a lot
more funding pressure on science I mean
you you're probably well aware of this
I'm sure all the scientists you speak to
tell you about this
so when funding it's tight obviously
that can lead to certain negative
tendencies including the fact that
scientists then have to have a stronger
will to brand themselves in order to
kind of stand out above the fray so I
mentioned that article science and the
age of selfies and that's really what
goes on a little bit again
understandable reasons you've got to
survive you got to make a living and so
there's a lot less again interconnection
okay reaching out to others questioning
others too I mean just take this is not
an a good example in the sense that how
extreme it is but in the old day like
Bohr and Einstein they had these debates
on quantum mechanics and they had them
all the time they fought and they're
great friends they fought they fought
they fought they discussed some people
could say those debates you know what's
the productivity nowadays would be like
well how many papers are resulting from
the debates but back of course those
were great Dana need to worry about that
because they already had plenty of
papers but the point is is intellectual
rumination ideation there's not a lot of
time for it because that will by
definition cut your short-term
productivity as far as publishable items
and if it's a dog-eat-dog world where
you're competing for grants that have a
success rate of five to ten percent what
are you going to do so scientist is in a
very difficult situation these days
because the incentive structure is
completely out of whack
yeah that's so critical that every time
that we try and have the this
intellectual nuanced illumination
reflection discourse is that not being
productive during that time not building
your brand getting not competing the
attention economy at that moment exactly
and this is one of the benefits of being
able to do things like this I think is
that we get to have this nuanced
discourse potentially inspire and engage
other people to care about it and
and that that that it kind of brings
those two things a little bit together
so hopefully there's maybe more of these
you know here we are right III human the
human while other people can watch from
around the world that maybe don't get
the opportunity to sit down with them
MIT research scientists I encourage my
clap I deliver to tell my class I want
you to do 10% of the speaking yeah I
don't want it to be in there like
shocked by this because it's just not
the way the system works they're
supposed to go retain information do the
exam no I don't want them to do that I
want them to think I want them to
challenge me own argue with me yeah yeah
exactly
I love that and that way you can get the
the young 20 30 year-old minds even
younger 15 sometimes you just sometimes
throw you a good interesting curve soul
and then that can be how we can if they
help teach me if they really want to
think about these things I'm sure they
have plenty of things and I have been
taught things by my students and I will
continue to be taught things by the
students and I hope the more they teach
me better off with both our and on the
way out this question about geopolitics
you mentioned at the beginning in your
in your state of the world answer it it
seems as though there's a period of deep
spiritual actualization and
transcendence that we need to go through
to understand more of the of the of the
sheer miracle it is that we all share
this rock orbiting a star together and
that we were so privileged that the
hundred billion humans before us got
that all of these ubiquity zand the
basic physiological needs that we have
so
what are on that geopolitical level but
is there is there is there a thought
that comes to mind to assist with that
spiritual growth that we all need I
think the hard part is this concept that
is very non-intuitive that in molding
our environment to shape say our
short-term needs we can actually do
long-term structure to the whole planet
and it's understandable why we don't
think this way because for the entirety
of human civilization we couldn't affect
our planet adversely right when we were
just hunters and gatherers there's
nothing we could really do to adversely
affect our planet so that encourage is
unbridled and Genuity where you do
whatever it takes to make the quality of
your life better and that's a great
system and that's worked but now there
are these externalities arising even
economists acknowledge their
externalities pollution global warming
all these things these are our to wrap
our head around unless we understand
them I am hopeful that the next
generation the younger generation will
understand them much better because it's
being inculcated in the school curricula
my only concern is you know will it be
too late or how late how much damage
will be done but ultimately we have to
get our heads wrapped around the idea
that we can actually adversely affect
the planet doing something trying to be
ingenious at a local scale that never
caused any harm before but it does now
that's just the way it's worked we have
to adjust we have to adapt and if we
don't adapt we're going to pay a big
price but that is a very very difficult
concept yeah and on the way out last two
questions that we're like asking our
guests first question is are we in a
simulation no to me that's kind of a
ridiculous idea one of the other neuro
myths that I like to dispel I have a
little neural mist lecture in my class
and this is like this is that you can
download your brain to a computer
I don't know where this stuff comes from
but it's really hard to understand why
people would say these things and for
the downloading the brain to your
computer which surprisingly I actually
gave that question to my class last year
I haven't yet asked this year's class
and more than half of them thought that
they could download in the future it's
in theory possible to do this and this
is just a fundamental misunderstanding
of the kind of the grounding problem
right I mean I can do a computer
simulation of a lot of different things
right and what I'm doing is I'm focusing
on one or two features of that thing it
doesn't make it isomorphic to the thing
if I simulate right a water molecule on
my computer is it wet you know am I
going to drink it no what you're doing
is you're simulating various features of
it various aspects of it right but it's
funny you know people don't ask that
question but they're like maybe we can
put our brain well you can't put water
onto a computer right and then there are
all kinds of grounding issues and
parallel systems versus discrete systems
and Turing machines and stuff like that
so I mean it's wrong on multiple levels
but I mean I guess the problem there is
that sci-fi culture is so prevalent that
the people don't necessarily go to the
scientist ask them to think about these
things carefully they just say oh isn't
this a cool movie and it seemed that
with chips in the brain right everyone's
putting a chip in the brain chips in the
brain normally work very well told me a
long time if ever before chips in the
brains work so you got to think about
these things carefully right and not
just jump to conclusions because it's
cool and it's in that scientific fiction
movie science fiction movie that I
enjoyed yeah yeah and really think
deeply about ethical considerations the
democratization of the technology the
accessibility of it for many other
people absolutely all that's important
but that people know about they think
about that those things actually which
is good well the big imaginations very
important too because maybe there are
potentially ways in of
a long time from now to be able to do oh
I'm all for that but people need to
think about these things carefully
instead of just kind of going off the
handle and saying wow this is possible
I'm sure I can do it you know no this is
very deep very nuanced a very subtle
question you need to think carefully
about it yeah so if you were to simulate
a water molecule in a world how could
you make that molecule feel wet to the
animals in that in that world so that's
a great great question and how about the
last questions what is the most
beautiful thing in the world well I mean
I think there's a certain elegance and
symmetry in the laws that govern the
universe and at multiple scales not just
the scale of physics but chemistry and
biology somehow elegant codifying
principles filter down at almost all
levels and scales that allow us to
comprehend the world you know the old
quote the most incomprehensible thing
about the worlds that are so
comprehensible I mean it's just I
believe it was attributed to Einstein I
mean it's an amazing aspect of existence
that there's so much of it that we can
understand even though there's lots we
don't understand and we certainly
understand more than we almost have a
right to think we could ever understand
so that's always boggled my mind and it
probably will continue to boggle it yeah
this has been such an honor thank you
Robert thank you very much I appreciate
it really we really appreciate it as
well I want everyone to share more ideas
around the differences between computers
and brains around neuroscience and
consciousness definitely get me talking
more about the nuance of these concepts
of your friends your family online your
co-workers get chatting about and
sharing about it check out Roberts link
below in the bio as well and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations around the world that
you believe in simulations links are
below support us help us continue doing
cool things like coming to MIT and doing
interviews and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon